ELIZABETH CHOE: We were
talking about like,
what is digital media
literacy exactly, because we
talked about this a lot.
And I think what it really is,
is not so much being proficient
in scripting and
filming and editing,
it's just the self awareness
to know what you're good at,
and what you're not good at.
And just the
appreciation for what
goes into things,
and the knowledge
of who to tap into to
help you create a project
or help you
communicate something.
Go ahead.
JOSHUA GUNN: I just
have a question
because I'm not plugged
into the MIT community,
or even into the scientific
community, for that matter.
But is there a culture
of sort of individuality
wherein this notion that
basically, my intellectual work
is to be done sort of in a
silo, versus the kind of,
like, I know I'm
not good at this,
so I need to build a
team where we can build.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: At MIT, it's
pretty interdisciplinary.
What I would say, is
not siloed, but there's
an ingrained culture of is
this idea that real science--
and I'm doing it now by saying
real science-- that science
and engineering is work, and
communication is not work.
JOSHUA GUNN: Oh, I see.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Or even
that it a separate thing.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
CHRIS BOEBELThat's a pretty
good way of putting it.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So that's-- it's
not that people are like siloed
within themselves, it's that
communicators don't have street
cred with scientists, period.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And that
part will just happen,
it will take care of itself.
I'm not going to worry
about it too much.
JOSHUA GUNN: I
see, so that sounds
like the real meat
of what you guys are
trying to work on, in a way.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, I guess.
I mean it's interesting because
I gave a survey to the students
at the end of the class,
and they were all like,
I probably wouldn't make
another video again.
A couple of them said they
would, but most of them
are like, I probably
won't make a video,
but, I have so much more
appreciation for what
goes into it.
Now I can't watch a
movie without thinking
about how much,
you know, how much
work it took to just
light the scene.
So even just having
the appreciation
for what goes into it,
I think, is a big step.
But, again, with the
whole literacy thing,
just the awareness of how
important these skills are.
Because, like you
said, I mean, it's
just crazy that we think
of them as separate things.
There's science and
there's communication,
and you're trained
separately on these things,
if you happen to be a
science communicator.
CHRIS BOEBEL: One of
things that I think
is really interesting about
media is that video or media,
films, they're really
interesting in that when
they're well made,
they're so accessible.
They're so immediately
graspable by those of us
in the last 100
years who's really
literate at unpacking video
and understanding the medium.
They're so kind of
intuitively open
that people who don't have
any appreciation or awareness
of how they're made
assume that there isn't
any kind of effort behind them.
That they just kind of happen.
And I can remember as a
kid kind of thinking that.
Never really
thinking about movies
and how they were made until, I
was probably, God, in college.
I just kind of assumed
that they just kind of
happened out there.
JOSHUA GUNN: Our clients
think you just hit a button.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's because if things
are well made, it's like,
didn't that just
always exist that way?
You mean somebody actually
had to create that?
It seems so natural.
And I think that
one of the things,
a key of media literacy,
is breaking that myth.
JOSHUA GUNN: Right.
Or, gasp, it would cost
money to hire people.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And take time.
JOSHUA GUNN: You would have
to hire professionals to do it
that are trained and pay them.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So
the biggest thing
in teaching this
literacy, though, I think,
is making them go through
the experience themselves.
Because it's one thing if
you watch like a series of
lectures.
Like it's one thing if you
watch this on OpenCourseWare,
and you can take
the notes on, like,
this is good framing if
you use the thirds rule.
Write a script like
you would say it.
We go through all these sort
of tangible, take home points.
These sort of plastic
elements, like you mentioned.
But I don't think
you'll have the same,
you won't draw the same value
from it as if you actually
go through and try
to do the projects
that these students did.
And that's a big issue, I think,
especially in media teaching.
That it's easy to
first establish
a sort of theoretical
principles.
Like, this is sort of
what makes a good story.
And then it's another
thing to actually give
hard, tangible
examples to students.
Like, look at this script.
They're able to point out
issues in the scripts.
They were able to critique
them, but then it's
a whole other step for them
to be able to integrate
it themselves into a script.
So you'd have a student who
understood the principles,
they took the notes,
they could reiterate
everything you said to them.
They were able to look at
the examples you gave them
and say, oh you know,
this is unclear here,
this is awkward wording.
And then they would write the
script, and you'd be like,
there's this disconnect
to the third step.
And it wasn't until
they tried it,
and then we were able to
critique them directly
that they were able to come
to this final self awareness
conclusion.